okay let's start this game welcome to
this video in the dark many new handles
yeah or people get check new ones every
day nah that's it's relatively new
account okay the bogo with night and 2 d
2 i'm going to play the castle slide
this is much sharper and then other
lines each for now yeah it's all the
rage yeah black has to play this move
there is no other no other move to play
and it leads to a very very sharp blade
let's see what we got and the main
problem basically for black is to
remember to remember them the lines okay
Bishop Bishop is aiming at g6 early
Quincy to do you play Queenie a TIA to
cover this hmm night c5 is also an
option but here Bishop g6 is going to
work so really Queenie ate a hard time
to remember okay let's do it haven't
looked at this this line for a while
knight c6 I guess he has just cancelled
so he has given up on the idea of
quickly um checkmating checkmating me
okay let's
play 95 it's not clear if I need to do
that but I have to see that I get my my
pieces out I'm taking night takes allows
the night coming to d6 possibly hmm
Bishop Bishop e2 they are not clear to
me I can also play Queen f7 to f5 I
don't know if I want to give him the
opportunity to put the night to the six
it's a bit a bit annoying this idea ok
maybe play with Queen to f5
maybe also preparing loop to aid the
right moment okay so he gives up on this
idea the Queen put mean putting the
night on d6 doesn't look very scary to
me at first okay let's take it so b5
yeah p5 is a bit bit uncomfortable to
face
and maybe I have to play it anyway I
mean 11 Bishop d7 maybe I have to play
it anyway ok is not ideal here but term
the night on the eighth but it has a
test possibilities on f7 later how do I
get it to have seven though don't see it
yeah okay maybe I have to go with night
b7 not be 72 c 5
now my dark squares are a bit shaky I
would have liked to put the night on f7
but not not positive that I could have
managed that b6 is weakening is
weakening them c6 quite a bit
yeah I want to irritate him a little bit
him but okay I cannot really go Quincy
form yeah at least 94 is not possible
that was the main idea maybe he can
still play it for Knight f6 right it was
an idea I am he could have maybe played
that 95 was maybe possible I know I'm
running right into it that was it wasn't
too clever didn't really see that this
one is coming how does kind of cans
embarrassing check
Diane when he gets to f7 ever play
Bishop g5 I to see Sapna mean
unfortunately
yeah just belong at 290 FOIA that was
that was completely completely
unnecessary really and 97 I cannot play
I look c7 sorry when Roxy 7 yeah I'm
still going to try to hang on being the
exchange down
the bishop on d5 is still fairly strong
so I can can try to try to hang on okay
you have the 20 seconds is actually the
the position is not great yeah but 20 20
seconds is an additional problem
check yeah okay black resign yeah it was
just a bad game I just played it really
really badly ok let's see you are on TM
and so it went went to this
Queen f7 ip3 yeah so when here should be
completely okay with the night on b3 and
so on so that the d6 squares and
weakness just i'd have to have to play
it well i don't have to be have to play
good move Sam
huh the computer has given a very
interesting movie g5 that's really an
interesting move I of course I didn't
consider that one at all using this
using the doubling on the FDF file
that's a mess interest an interesting
way to play it I didn't think about that
at all ok I played two plate nala move
and went here back here now we took it
with this so rook c8 this is really so
bad I have a hard time to believe that
that this should be so bad but maybe it
is yeah the night on dat hmm do I have
to play g5 I have to admit that I that I
forgot forgot my preparation here but
Queenie 8 Queen yet i think i have to
play here and went here and this yeah
this is always debatable if you want to
prevent before or not but i thought it
didn't make so much sense to maybe queen
of seven is wrong thats possible even if
i can't play with g5 it's not clear that
i need to to do that computer suggest a
six sets it's interesting just waiting
for a moment and prepare to take and
play be five yeah it assesses the
situation as equal and taking taking on
c4 looks bit uncomfortable with this
happening
I don't like that even if the computer
thinks it's it's roughly okay it takes
takes yeah g5 mg5 is a cool move that
gives counter player this gives counter
blamed and my king position is fairly
safe interesting idea i know i didn't
think about that at all here probably a
bit too passive yeah yeah i really i
should be should be okay again i don't
really think it's so bad went here went
back i actually I really forgot that 94
still in there it is really better yeah
I completely ignored it I just like that
blunder to that and here you know here
the position is is already more than
critical I'm not not totally sure about
this year but it should win yet with the
bed structure what should what should
win this it is not so easy sometimes
with the exchange up when the black porn
structure the defending porn structures
is compact but that's not the case here
okay hope you liked it thanks for
watching